last Victor of the day is with us begim
welcome back to the show
congratulations this was a difficult
game uh it didn't seem like it's going
your way out of the opening at least not
more than a draw it seems like you did
equalize with the black pieces but in
the end game you tried and pushed and
pushed and finally it paid off how are
you feeling right now hi guys thank you
so much uh I'm a bit tired I did did
expect a long game because uh she plays
E4 E5 this uh Bishop like you know
Spanish and then C4 lines is also
possible so I didn't expect much I just
tried to uh get a game basically and
then have a long game but I didn't
expect it was going to be that long and
of course she was totally fine even in
the middle game but she started to burn
a lot of time and when she had time
trouble I I think she just misevaluated
the position I thought thought she
missed KN King D7 King D6 idea after
that she should be very careful and
after the time uh King D7 King D6 at
move 34 as we were getting close to the
second time
control yeah right I think she she
thought it's going to be very
comfortable draw but suddenly my
position is uh slightly better and I can
just push I can uh play G5 H4 and then
go back with the Rook it's just going to
be like forever uh torture for her and
it was at this moment after Knight to C2
where she should have taken your Pawn
but instead sh away from very upset
about it yeah I was very upset about it
I I felt like I should be winning I
thought I I I I will be winning after
Rook C5 and after she played Rook C5 I
started to calculate and I didn't really
see anything Knight E3 King E1 and now
she has to go back to E1 and perhaps
that was the move that she didn't like
making exactly because if she does go to
C1 you have Rook to A1 and this is in
fact a win for
you yeah I saw that one like King she
needs to hold the King on E1 and
suddenly I just don't have anything
that's right and I I said like it's okay
anyways Knight C2 is my best try and she
played Rook C3 now I'm pushing again I
have a pawn up probably rook and game at
some point it was it was a draw even
instead of King E3 King King G5 was a
better try
but she just had no time at that point
this uh Rook end game was uh very very
difficult and we were looking at the
best moves we couldn't understand it
with the help of the engine um so I
don't blame you for missing a couple of
things here and there for example at
this point Rook to A3 was not the right
move Rook to B3 was uh the win so that
you hide the King on the B file whenever
she starts giving you checks
I mean this type of detail is definitely
not easy to understand King to F3 once
again winning with this move Rook to D6
but you play the move E4 and you
mentioned yeah exactly that's why I was
thinking actually at this point I
stopped a little bit I felt like E4 and
Rook uh D6 are good options I felt like
Rook D6 is winning yes for some reason I
just had the feeling uh but my uh brain
is you know thinking and E4 seems
logical position I just yeah exactly I
just had a feeling Rook D6 she doesn't
have any checks she needs to move the
king and I'm winning winning a Tempo
somehow and then King G4 E4 is winning
so I thought there's no difference and
then I started to realize that there is
a huge difference actually in between so
it's just my pawns are running here and
as you were mentioning uh King to G5 was
in fact also a very good move for her
instead of King to E3 yeah uh she did
play King to E3 and still it wasn't easy
check
check and now after King to E3 she had
this final opportunity to make the draw
with Rook to h8 did you spot this one
it's ridiculous no you want to go H6
H7 yeah just push I can do that yeah I I
thought it's it's a good idea actually
for her to play that I wasn't sure if
I'm queening or not I thought okay she
has time trouble if she finds everything
right what can I do like yeah uh so I
just thought it's my just uh final try
and it paid off I saw that she has this
idea yeah and it paid off because she
played I believe that this this end game
should be should be a draw but I
couldn't figure out how I I I can see
the options she can see the options but
it's just so hard to calculate and
evaluate the position maybe with a few
hours on the clock it would be uh easier
with just a couple of seconds never easy
well beging congratulations once again
you're keeping pace with Karissa in this
one she's not letting go you're not
letting go this is going to be a race to
the Finish Line congratulations we'll
see you tomorrow thank you guys
absolutely our congratulations as well B
is uh